as ant-man 3 ebin lost to the quantum
realm forever a source allegedly close
to Marvel Studios is reporting that a
three quill for the tiny Avenger isn't
going to happen and that ant-man and the
wasp may see their further adventures
relegated to the upcoming Disney Plus
streaming service the rumor comes
courtesy of rumormonger Mikey Sutton who
points to two reasons in particular for
the decision to shrink Scott Lang and
hope Van Dyne down from the big screen
to the small one first Marvel Studios
head honcho Kevin Feige is said to be
preoccupied with the task of folding the
x-men and Fantastic Four along with the
other formerly Fox own properties
recently acquired by Marvel's parent
company Disney into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe something he alluded to at San
Diego comic-con 2019 second Sutton
claims that Feige is invested in
exploring different genres with the
emcee use phase four and phase five
offerings from spy thrillers to
psychological horror flicks and
everything in between so apparently
there simply won't be any room left on
the slate for more conventional
superhero adventures we submit however
that this is nothing new for the MCU
which has played in different genres for
years now but we digress let's look at
this rumor from a pure common-sense
standpoint the Feige is just too busy
angle has been dragged out in one other
recent situation has a pretty thin
excuse on the part of Sony Pictures CEO
Tony Vincey Keira as to why his studio
and Disney couldn't reappear agreement
to share custody of spider-man you'll
notice that it's not actually Feige
complaining about how busy he is in
either circumstance it's other parties
putting those words in his mouth for him
which seems a little suspect as we
alluded to before
it also doesn't make a heck of a lot of
sense to advance the notion that because
Marvel wants to do some different things
with some of its upcoming features at
the forthcoming blade reboot legacy
heroes and/or their future franchises
must be left behind if that were the
case we certainly wouldn't be getting
Thor love and thunder an unprecedented
fourth film for an original Avenger one
could even make the argument
ant-man and his supporting characters
were more important to the MCU s
overarching narrative through phase
three than virtually any others the
ant-man films introduced the technology
that made it possible for the Avengers
to travel through time and acquire all
of the Infinity stones before Thanos
could if Laing hadn't been freed from
the quantum realm by the timely
intervention of a mouse the universe
would be toast yes that's a mouse
officially the ant-man flicks may be the
lightest and brizia STUV the MCS
franchises but they've been charged with
doing a surprising amount of narrative
heavy lifting and while they haven't
exactly blown up the box-office they
haven't flopped either together totaling
over 1.1 billion dollars worldwide all
of these points aside it's worth
considering that a couple of sources
that we know to be close to Marvel
Studios namely Paul Rudd and co-star
Michael Douglas have made public remarks
indicating that ant-man 3 isn't off the
table during a Television Critics
Association presser back in February
Douglass indicated that while nothing
has been formalized there had absolutely
been talks about ant-man 3 although he
didn't expect to hear whether it was
actually going down until quote its
third rewrite as for Rudd he simply gone
on record stating that he doesn't know
when or if ant-man 3 will happen as
recently as June although it's possible
that he knows more than he's letting on
so will there be an ant-man 3 the simple
fact is that we don't know but we have
no compelling reason right now to think
that there won't be the ant-man flicks
have served a valuable purpose as fun
light palette cleansers in between huge
universe shaking events and we think
it's pretty likely that the MCU will be
in need of another one of those at some
point also mr. Feige if you're watching
this please know that if fans never get
the chance to hear Lang's motormouth
Buddy Louise recount the events of
Avengers and gain in his own inimitable
fashion you can expect about 4 million
sternly worded emails ok sorry you know
what I just get excited as them check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]